yesterday uh and the night before it
actually started the night before on
monday night was was a crazy crazy time
so this whole story is breaking all this
spotify stuff and the sensor stuff and
he said the n-word and all of the stuff
that i've just laid out here is breaking
well on monday
i had a big meeting in sarasota rumble
just opened up huge offices in sarasota
they were getting the uh most of the
team not the entire team we have people
all literally all over the world
programmers in eastern europe and spain
and all over the place but we were
getting the entire team people in canada
and the united states together as many
other people as we could for a first
company-wide meeting and as you guys
know locals the company that i started
to fight all of this stuff we merged
with rumble about six months ago and the
reason we did it was because they have
the distribution they have the the right
set of people involved to fight cancel
culture to stand up for the principles
that i'm always talking about here uh
you know it's like it doesn't take
village to build to raise a child but it
does take a village to fight big tech
and you can't do it on your own all the
time i didn't think i could just do it
on my own so we found the right allies
to merge with so we merge these
companies we're building some really
awesome stuff to stand up against
youtube to stand up against amazon aws
the whole thing and to defend free
speech so anyway there was a big
company-wide meeting there that had
nothing to do with the rogan thing this
this had been planned for weeks
on monday and on sunday night the whole
you know people were arriving from all
over the world and we went out to this
big dinner and we're all sitting at the
table and everyone's talking about joe
rogan because obviously this is not only
the thing that's happening right now but
it's certainly related to the work that
rumble's doing and what i do and
everything else
and i just said to everybody at the
table i was sitting across from chris
the the ceo the rumble ceo and i was
sitting across from assaf the ceo of uh
locals and a bunch of the other people
some of the lawyers and whatever else
and i said you know we need to just do
something nuts why don't why don't we
just make a hundred million dollar offer
to rogan publicly like can we do that
let's just do that and i was like sort
of kidding but also not kidding like i
don't actually know how much money
rumble has i was just like you know
let's just do let's just shock the
system that's what i kept saying the
system needs to be shocked we need to
show people that there's a chance and
that people will fight and something and
chris just freaking lit up a soft lit up
and it was everybody was like holy [ __ ]
that that's a freaking great idea like
that's what we should do that's what we
should do and chris immediately turns to
the lawyer can we do that and the lawyer
starts like kind of thinking and
mumbling a little bit
and then chris gets on the phone with
somebody they got to call an accountant
they call a bunch of people and then
chris comes back about 10 minutes later
we're going to do it we're going to do
it and we're sitting there and everybody
50 people everybody is going holy cow
this is freaking amazing like we're
actually gonna do something we're gonna
we're gonna give it our best shot right
like we're gonna offer rogue in the
off-ramp like if you don't like the
censorship of spotify i don't know
everything about his deal there
but if you don't like it and there's a
way to extricate yourself from that
situation hey you got a home here we'll
take all your stuff we will never censor
you do whatever the hell you want and
here's 100 freaking million dollars to
do it so the offer that we made was 100
authentic and then the next morning
uh chris the rumble ceo tweeted this out
and if i could just pat myself on the
back for a second i wrote it so there
you go i did have a little bit of help
but uh these are my words i think you'll
hear me in this dear joe
we stand with you your guests and your
legion of fans and desire for real
conversation so we'd like to offer you
100 million reasons to make the world a
better place how about you bring your
shows to rumble both old and new with no
censorship for a hundred million bucks
over four years this is our chance to
save the world and yes this is totally
legit sincerely chris pavlovsky rumble
ceo i think you can hear my voice in
that thing i was the one i really pushed
they wanted to put dollars a hundred
million dollars instead of bucks i said
let's just do bucks
make it friendly so the offer is real i
want to be very clear about that i saw a
bunch of people the usual suspects and
blue check haters and all that stuff
it's not a real offer and they don't
have the money and blah blah blah it is
a real offer joe rogan or anyone
associated with joe rogan if you are
watching this take 100 million dollars
from rumble you will be completely
uncensored you can do whatever you want
to do and your entire catalog can be up
on rumble tomorrow maybe today
i'd have to talk to the people but it is
completely legit